-You shot in New Orleans.
Was it fun
shooting in new Orleans?
It was during
an actual festival, right?
-It was during
the Essence Music Festival,
which happens every summer
around the Fourth of July.
And a half a million people
descend on the city --
mostly women --
black women, at that.
And so it was, like,
just this culture,
this fun, all this music.
You're seeing, like,
your favorite performers --
everybody from New Edition
to Puff Daddy
to Mariah Carey, Doug E. Fresh.
You know, so, we were shooting
in all of these scenes
we're creating,
but it's really
their performances --
their actual performances
that were happening.
So it was hard to concentrate.
You wanted to kind of party.
-Well, I can also imagine,
it must be hard
because you must be
so recognizable
to everybody
at a festival like that.
-Uh, yeah.
-Because you could
just as easily be one of
the people performing at it.
-Exactly.
-So, do people approach you
all the time when
you were in New Orleans?
Was it kind of constant?
-Oh, definitely.
But people from New Orleans
are really cool.
The tourists who came in town
were probably
more excited to see me.
But the locals are like,
"Oh, hey, baby. You good?"
They tell you where
to get the good gumbo,
the étouffée, and the drinks.
I mean, you got to love a town
where you can get
a drive-through daiquiri.
-Yeah.
-They got a drive-through.
-They figured it out.
-I'm like,
"Let me get this right.
You can drive
and then take this big old
slushie of daiquiri,
and she's legal?
Okay."
I love this place.
I always have.
But, yeah, one scene,
we shot in the Superdome
while, I think,
Mariah Carey was performing.
And we were trying to figure out
how to do this.
We know we only have
one, maybe two takes.
By the third one, there's no way
everybody is not
gonna recognize us,
'cause this is our fan base.
You know what I mean?
So we got away
with the first one.
The second one,
we got, like, a "Jada!"
or "Latifah!"
-[ Laughs ]
-By the third one, it was like,
"Regina! Jada! Latifah!
Wait! Look here!"
-[ Laughs ]
-It was, like,
so many camera phones pointed,
we couldn't -- That was it.
The jig is up.
-We'll assume,
when we see the film,
the first take was
the one you used.
-The first take was the one.
There's no way.
-You talked about,
signing that first contract,
going from Latifah
to Queen Latifah.
Do you remember --
When success first came,
do you remember
the first thing you bought
when you kind of signed
that first big contract?
-[ Chuckles ]
We bought stupid stuff
with the first money we got,
I must say.
You know, you give a 17-year-old
that kind of dough...
-i had no money at 17.
I was, like, later.
So, I got, like,
a flat-screen and a couch.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good thing
to have at 17.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I got -- I gave --
I would always give
a third to my mom...
-Oh, that's nice.
-...and a third
to put away for taxes,
which was all right at the time.
[ Laughter ]
Doesn't work...
Works for trump,
but not for me.
[ Laughter ]
For us normal people.
And I would blow the other third
because I'm 17.
-What does a 17--
-I bought a Jeep Wrangler...
-All right, that's good.
-...and a gold tooth.
-[ Chuckling ] A gold tooth?
[ Laughter ]
-I always wanted a gold tooth.
I was, like, super hip-hop kid
back then.
And I couldn't afford
a gold tooth or a gold chain.
My brother and I would share
the same chain
that was really my mother's.
[ Laughter ]
So we circulated
a lot of stuff like that.
And I wanted a gold tooth.
So I bought
this, like, cheap gold tooth
at a kiosk in the mall.
[ Laughter ]
It didn't fit.
You had to squeeze it
to make it stick on,
and it would pop off
and it would pop out.
And I had to stay like this
to even use it.
I lost that thing in a day.
I was like, "Forget this.
This is dumb."
-Well, I'm glad
you treated yourself.
-Thank you.
And I'm glad things have
continued to go so well.
It's just always
such a pleasure to see you.
Thank you for being here.
-Glad to be here, Seth.
Keep rockin' out.
-Congrats on the film.
-Thanks, Queen Latifah.
-Peace, everybody!